going back to something you said about
how you came off the success of one film
and then another film that you enjoyed
making you felt it wasn't a successful
in some sense though don't you think
that that then further prepares you and
makes that you draw that line in the
sand knowing that that's the ebb and
flow of being an artist as an ebb and
flow of having a brand of being in a
band that you're going to have some that
are perceived one way and some that
aren't but if you really still want to
do this you get back and you do it again
and you know that that's kind of the
risk that's a very mature way of looking
at it out of that if I had that maturity
you know are you you just because you're
just furious because it's out of your
hand we put as much time it was the same
team as the other movie we put edge as
much time and love into this movie as we
did in to the other movie and then to
see a company do nothing with it for
whatever reasons financial it wasn't
that they didn't love the movie or
anything but you're just helpless it's
this profound feeling of helplessness
and tagalog if people could only see
this movie I think they would appreciate
it you know and that so i don't know if
i had the distance to go like oh that is
just the ebb and flow of the creative
process that's beautifully put because
it gives it that poetry but i didn't
experience it as poetry in the moment I
think right well I'm and believe me this
is not like how i dictate my life every
day either I mean every all get upset
over something not working out but I
think if you have time to reflect on it
and say because I've known a lot of
people that have been frustrated and
said nope I'm done leaving right tired
of this it didn't work this person it is
so that but if you know that if you
could have some distance somehow bring
in a paycheck however that is and then
go okay this might be part of how
someone sustains a career sure no you're
sure that that is probably true that if
you can't deal with the failures you
won't have a career
for sure for sure now with me I don't
it's one of those cases where I'm not
really good at anything else I don't
know what else my career if I could play
the guitar but try the rock star courier
I don't know so i know that i'll stick
with with narrative storytelling in
whatever form whether that's TV or
movies or whatever so that at least when
I panic and I'm frustrated I don't go
out of outside of that box and go like
let me become a gardener or something
i'm staying within the you know what can
we do with in there and it's kind of the
same thing though you want to work with
material that you find stimulating and
interesting and that's not generic and
then it's almost secondary where it ends
up I mean of course it's nicer if it
ends up on the big screen at the
arclight and you know 3,000 screens then
on VOD on iTunes or something but really
the creative process that you go through
is absolutely exactly the same and
also to sorry interrupt you um that that
knowing there isn't really anything else
you'd have a desire to do because I
heard someone say that the other day
like oh I'm not trained for something
else but I know that person is bright
enough to do whatever they put their
mind to what it's having that impetus to
get you out of bed to do that right and
if it's only thing that gets you out of
bed is knowing that ok I have a6 a.m.
call time and i'll i'll get ready for
this those are the days i can i prefer
to stay in bed though when i have a 6am
call talk maybe about it now as you go
through all I don't know I've always
fatalistic maybe that's a cultural
German thing that I always think like
today is the day when everything will go
wrong and everything will fall apart
every night after shoot i'm genuinely
surprised i'm going to day went really
well we got away with it one more day
tomorrow is going to be a catastrophe
but today with it and then when I think
back I don't think I've ever had a bad
shooting day where I didn't go home and
was like today was amazing and yet I
always fall for that that I'm terrified
of the next day and of not being
prepared for the next day and I think
like project after project that get a
little bit better at letting go I just
got it's this thing you know and going
like whatever will happen and have
be a hundred percent prepared because
I've been doing it long enough or I'm
working with people that have been doing
it long enough that we can react to
things that don't go completely
according to plan you know but that's a
very slow process to kind of for that to
sink into my bones and for me not to be
terrified in the mornings everyone
that's good in some ways I think there's
an over confidence in American culture I
think that we've been groomed to be oh I
got this you know where we're gonna do
this let's show you know I wish I had
that I would take good money for some of
that confidence it has its good sites
and it's bad sites i think like with my
pessimism usually i am over prepared you
know so that's a good thing but on the
other hand if i look back at that shoots
now we had such a good time and I'm kind
of like I wish I had enjoyed that more
and not my head half my brain being
terrified of what tomorrow might bring
like if I had known the outcome in
advance I would have enjoyed the journey
much more so I'm now trying to
consciously do that even with with
difficulties because it's I'm so
privileged how great to see these things
how great to see a genuine Hollywood
diva being difficult and being a
nightmare from the first row you know
how great but of course at that moment
you don't feel that way you just go like
that woman is destroying my life and I
don't know how to do the scene because
she's being difficult but if I can just
step back at go like I get to spend my
workday seeing that first rate data I
wouldn't want to do anything else right
you can pull out the ebb and flow card
we're exactly I don't like it ever poked
or t-shirt instead of have a nice day
yeah heaven fled
you